the monster verse has slowly and
steadily been given us hints at its next
move in the upcoming godzilla vs kong
movie
that will be released this coming year
so in this video we will be showing you
the nine
updates that we have compiled to keep up
the hype
as we all know the production run has
already been delayed even before the
pandemic started but because of it
we will get the movie until next year
such a bummer i know
it's for the best i hope but anyway here
is the list of 9 interesting things that
have happened in gvk even though we are
waiting eagerly for the trailer to throw
us some more light
into what is in store for all of us
let's start with gong's design and the
2017 kong this titan is a hundred plus
foot tall ape daikaiju that has been in
the movie screens for more than 87 years
and all throughout the years his design
has constantly changed
and have seen a lot of increases in size
and also decreases depending upon the
movies but in the most of us they have
ducked back into the 60s version
and created a gigantic version of it
upright in stature and very intelligent
and with an unmatched brute strength and
agility
the godzilla vs kong version as we have
seen in a few leaked clips
will pull the creature up to a height
that is similar to that of the g-man
he will most likely be more than 350
feet tall
and would spot a very viking beard on
his chin
he also looks like his muscle mass will
substantially increase and somehow be
more of a gorilla
in posture than the 2017 version
secondly the battle axe another major
update is that kong will be going into
battle
viking style not just with the beard but
with an axe as well
and if you're wondering what would be
durable enough for kong to use against
godzilla
well godzilla or at least a part of him
in the league toy images we saw battle
axe with kong that was fashioned from
one of godzilla's dorsal plates
so what is the significance well
godzilla's plate
can absorb energy directed at them as
well as store it
the axe could very well be a shield too
as
it could be used to defend against the
atomic breath and since kong has been
seen improvising with trees
propellers and chains as weapons he
could very well go
caveman style on the g-man with the axe
now number three godzilla's design now
going to the g-man his design will be
mostly similar to the king of the
monsters version
as not much has happened to him since
then in the previous movie we saw
godzilla grow taller and bulkier in
appearance as compared to the 2014
version
his dorsal plates have also grown more
and the four limbs as well as
legs seem to be more muscular and
prominent in the leaked clip
we saw the same godzilla but with again
minor changes that a few have noticed
most noticeably the more prominent and
even larger dorsal plates
but that might just be a glitch in the
system who knows
but also if you look closely his neck
seems to be shorter and stockier
but the toy designs show the same 2019
design so we will just have to wait and
see
then we have mega godzilla one
surprising toy figure revealed to us
bears the name
mega godzilla and it's not just directed
at the increase in size of the g-man
in fact it has a weird exoskeleton
covering him that
is red in color and seems to be grown
around him
it bears no resemblance to any past
designs
and there has never actually been
prosthetics or armor given to godzilla
in the past movies
it kinda looks like the parts of mecca
godzilla which we shall discuss later in
the video
and it seems that it was added to
godzilla maybe for power enhancement
or maybe he got into a great injury and
the only thing that would help
him up again against another opponent is
for the red exoskeleton to combine with
him
but that's just our theory the reason
for it the presence of this mega
godzilla toy however
brings a lot of questions for the movie
number five the alpha skull crawler
so up next we have the big skull crawler
an even bigger specimen than the one
that fought kong in the final scenes of
the 2017 kong skull island movie
this one is a large reptilian creature
and with only
2-4 limbs and no high limbs as well as a
long prehensile serpentine tail
you know the story just like its smaller
minions as we have done a video of the
three titans confirmed for gvk
we will make this short we'll call it
the alpha skull crawler
as it has reddish skin on it and it
starts from the base of the head
and the neck and goes backwards this
alpha also has
bigger arms with more musculature and
seems to be half the height of godzilla
but equal in length
but that's just a toy figure comparison
but again
imagine this beast fight with godzilla
rather than kong
seems like a battle worth watching next
we have the hollow
earth anti-gravity vehicle alongside the
giant skullcrawler we have a small
vehicle that was
a part of the toy figure and it was
named the heav
which is short for hollow earth
anti-gravity vehicle
as we all know ever since the 2017 skull
island movie
that the planet has huge underground
cavities that are theorized to contain
more titans and monsters in them
it was made true with the seismology
readings and the emergence of the skull
crawlers
and also in kotm when we found that
godzilla uses these cavities to travel
in and out around the seas of the planet
and there was also an ancient
civilization trap in the depths
so this heav is like the underwater
version of the argo of kotm
which would be used to travel the depths
of the hollow earth and since going down
would also see
the effect of gravity lessen the use of
anti-gravity like
the human ships in the matrix trilogy
films will be seen
before we continue on with the other
three updates for godzilla vs gong don't
forget to check out our merchandise on
dspring.com
so going up to number seven we have
nozuki or the warbap
so this island appears to be a winged
serpent-like creature with yellow and
red colored wings
see these updates are mostly from league
clips and toy league images so forgive
us if legendary pulls
them back and says no we will give them
other titans for the movie
but if the nazuki is closely inspected
we would see that the serpent has
strange wings that just
juts out from the sides and it comes out
from the spines of the creature like
the frills of the dilophosaurus in the
first jurassic park film
these wings are mostly used for either
gliding or for intimidation
and not for flying but we could end up
being surprised after all
godzilla can self-detonate and survive
this warbat or nuzuki will be the most
interesting talent to see in the
upcoming movie
then we get to mecca godzilla so as we
have seen in the credit scenes of kotm
monarch was actively building a
mechanized island in order to face off
against the other organic titans threat
that humanity suddenly faced
in the recent years it wouldn't be
far-fetched since mechagodzilla has been
a staple in the godzilla franchise and
is one of the recurring enemies faced by
the g-man
did you know that the head of ghidorah
in the past has been salvaged and used
to build
make a godzilla with it well we all know
that there is still
one head of monster zero in isla de mara
so
in the league toy images we can see that
there is in fact a mecha godzilla and it
has a very
different design although not really as
different as mecha godzilla city yeah
this mega godzilla had robust arms and
legs and that the hands were like clamps
that would likely be clenched to form a
powerful fist or grab
godzilla's neck this mecha also had
a long reddish spine and tail which
could be nuclear batteries for powering
the
titan and its attacks and lastly we have
the release date
the film was previously shared to be
released in may 29
then may 22nd pre-phone then pre-pawn to
max
then pre-pawn to march 13 2020
and then kicked to november 20th 2020
and however due to covet 19 pandemic
this film was pushed to its current may
2021 release
in february 2020 however warner bros
hosted an announced death screening
which
received a mostly positive response so
there won't be any future postponement
or cancellation
hopefully and so with that we end our
nine updates for godzilla vs skull movie
to be released
in the next year if some of you have any
further information do let us know in
the comment section
so we can pin your comments and others
will know as well
anyway it's been a blast do like and
share our video and don't forget to
click on the notification bell
for regular updates